alluring light sculptures in an endless
loop these are all animated gif files
they were created in the Turkish city of
Istanbul by multimedia artists about a
machine in his view the 90s computer
format is now on the cutting edge of
visual arts for energy the file type is
endlessly inspiring my fascination about
gifts is repetition because they doesn't
have a beginning or end it's repeating
like a circle so that gif format is
perfect for my videos if stumble is
where and are in she's lived and worked
for half a decade he began posting gifs
on his blog two years ago unlike more
modern image formats gives her supported
by all kinds of browsers and because
they aren't huge in size they're easy to
share EDI Lynch's art gifts
quickly took off online his works have
been liked more than a hundred and fifty
thousand times the best thing to her
blog is for me you can get instant
feedback
you can get instant comments so you
don't have to wait to exhibit your work
in a gallery in she is a spontaneous
artist he rarely plans his creations
today he's using a massive stencil to
make a new gift it's vital that there
are not many people around while he's
filming so he often records at night or
in the early morning to make sure his
on-camera movements are as consistent as
possible in she uses a metronome to keep
time in she often causes a stir when he
films passers-by check out what he's
doing and they end up in his videos it
takes him just half an hour to film what
he needs
afterwards he checks the outcome of his
work
when I do good
performance I don't know if it's work or
not so I need to experiment
I think it's the right way to find
something new since the start of the
decade gifts have been back in fashion
us photographers Kevin Berg and Jamie
Bank pioneered the trend called
cinemagraphs this work alone has been
clicked around 200 million times and
British artist Inza is famous for both
his graffiti and for his gifs since
their comeback gifts have escaped the
World Wide Web they've become part of
the urban landscape man they've gone
viral in the art world
to cultural critic a British Keane is a
big fan of gifts in the gallery and one
of the most contemporary art forms that
we are producing today and they are
short and
since we are following a lot of webpages
we are surfing on the internet so much
we get used to how to read the images
and
in a very quick way Ellen she is taking
advantage of the last rays of Sun to
make another animated gif filming
doesn't take long so the artists will be
in post-production for up to a week
there he had its down the images until
the final animated gif emerges in she
specializes in patterns that have got
more and more elaborate with time he's
always coming up with fresh ideas for
gifts
I would for example I would put a carpet
a large messy carpet made of Pumas on a
square
the Turkish artists incredible creations
are in great demand so a Dalian she
wanders through the empty streets of
Istanbul making it another animated gif
his latest light sculpture